big news Jim Norton's married that's a
very embarrassing thumbnail but it's
kind of it's it's kind of a goof that's
how I normally see his face
but and we're off but here's the reason
we're married now is because we first
started talking CU you're madly in love
I'm I mean I guess but we started
talking at the very end of 2016 on the
phone FaceTime every single day but I'm
like I'm going to book gigs I'll book
Oslo that's my first am Jim was in Oslo
when he did his European tour um and he
was going to fly me out and I missed my
flight but then the next day you got me
another flight yeah so you hadn't fully
transitioned by then oh yeah still
missing flights were we needed a couple
more hormones actually like nationally
it's like if you're transgender it's
kind of like you need a diagnosis and it
was a long road but it's like I do think
it is the right thing to do because
there's definitely something different
going on in the brain and you know
physically and under the
skirt so so it's very weird like when I
came here I noticed that a lot of PE
like in here in the states it's not like
that at all you know you can see a
doctor and you can start hormones but in
Norway you got to have a diagnosis it's
called
transgenderism okay so diagnosis
f64.0 or something and by the way that's
not the big news is not that we're
married like I know that that sounds
like we're we're starting a YouTube page
and that's kind of a joke that's like
the first five minute promo video iing a
YouTube page together is way more
commitment than getting married I think
so too it's so weird to see myself on
like Instagram and social media cuz I
was off the grid for literally five
years yeah so now that I'm back on it's
like I met J when I was 19 I'm 26 now
it's so weird that just now like 3 weeks
ago we're public I love it I mean I I
can't believe I'm saying that and
actually meaning it but I really love
being married like I don't want anything
else this is I love not having a job and
being a housewife too yeah we look at it
for different no but I have to say I've
never had a job and no literally I'm
never had a job I'm not trying to make
myself this person of weird spectacle
but I've never had a job and I love
living with Jim he's a very manic person
so whenever he gets home from Radio I
love waking up early now yeah yeah which
I never did before but he has a schedule
now so when he wakes up and go to work
the first thing I do wake up have the
apartment to myself coffee you know just
relax do all that but when he comes home
the radio voice is still on and it
drives me crazy like Nikki and it's just
so loud and crazy and I've had a nice
morning yoga I do a bath every morning
bubble bath
Waterworks I love it I this is feminism
but do you see the Dynamics I love being
married I never thought I love it so
much I love having the apartment to
myself no but you know what that's what
marriage is I went through some shit and
I've learned to wholeheartedly
prioritize myself first and being with
Jim it's easy cuz I have the freedom yes
I feminism this this is feminism
feminism when when you're in a marriage
like ours which again is very much
similar to most people's marriage yeah
this is but people are going to assume
they know things about it and that's why
we want to put stuff out whether it's
YouTube or on Instagram it's like if
you're going to judge us watch us and
then come to your own determination
based on what you see us doing I like
these two or I hate these two as opposed
to just oh this is what this marriage is
or this is what it's based on do you
know what I mean like totally you want
to have your own record of it so other
people aren't telling your story and and
saying what your life is and what it's
about do you feel like you have to
change a little bit some of the stuff
like are you ever like you know what
let's keep this part private there's
certain things I wouldn't talk about
like that you wouldn't in any
relationship but it feels so good to be
talking about it because I'm I'm very
open about my life so when I wasn't
talking about our relationship it was
torture i f remember I remember that
when he was like can we not talk about
this on the show like it really cuz I
wanted Nikki to get in the country and I
wanted to make sure that if we got
married we liked it like we wanted to
have a private life to make sure that
Rel that Jim is a little like we went to
his sister's house when I first came
into the country and it was Christmas so
I felt special and holidayish and you
know and his sister ceased the ring on
my finger my engagement ring and she
asks Jim like are you married and I'm
like wait you didn't tell your sister
we're married no no this was when we got
engaged we had gotten engaged I forgot
to tell my family you still say
boyfriend so let's just take let's just
take it easy my sister saw that and she
goes are you in you're engaged oh and I
was like oh I forgot to tell my family I
mean I justd sometimes I know when I
told my parents about Nikki we had
dinner and I told them like I met this
girl and I told them she's transgender
and then my you know my mother wants to
know like are you gay like she again it
was she didn't care but that really is
the big question though like are you gay
um no um I mean I'm not straight but
you're definitely not straight I mean I
don't when you're dick is out it don't
go
boo well you do but no voice comes out
[Laughter]
for the people another one all right but
um you know my my parents and how do you
navigate that you're just like I don't I
whatever it is she's a straight woman
but no can I have my take on it though I
feel like whatever whenever there's a
man yes and but I feel like as a man
whenever there's a dick in play um and
you're okay with it yeah it's very hard
to consider yourself heterosexual I
don't care how other people identify if
it if if it turns out someday someone
said you're totally heterosex great I
wouldn't believe that but I don't care
how other people look at it or how they
message though that the general people
are trying to come across that real
woman like let's not pretend you're
sitting here so pregnant that we're the
same person right right cuz we're not
like I don't get per hello like why do I
have to explain that you know what I
mean and people get so mad at you if you
give an answer that is not 100
put you in a box just help me put you in
a box every group has their thing where
if you're not 100% in line with the
ideology you're an enemy if you're if if
if you question or don't check every
single box of the of the ideological
belief you're an enemy and it's crazy
well also I can't think of anyone and
who's a d Lister B Lister C Lister I
don't who's married a transgender I
can't think of one person I've never
heard of it I've never read it and you
know Jim does it Smith where
h